ja ich finde heute ist ein tag zur
freude denn der europäische gerichtshof
hat endlich dargestellt und klargestellt
dass der rechtsstaat mechanismus scharf
geschaltet werden kann und zwar
gegenüber polen und gegenüber ungarn
beide staaten polen und ungarn sind
freiwillig mitglieder der europäischen
union geworden in beiden staaten gibt es
ganz viele menschen die hoffnungen
verknüpfen mit einer mitgliedschaft in
der europäischen union und wir müssen
feststellen dass die justiz immer weiter
beeinträchtigt wird das richter aus dem
amt entfernt werden empfohlen dass die
opposition in ihren rechten beschnitten
wird das medien platt gemacht werden
denn wunder und wenn so etwas passiert
dann ist das mit den rechten der
europäischen union nicht vereinbar wer
auf der einen seite so menschenrechte
rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie mit
füßen tritt da kann ich auf der anderen
seite dann auch noch gelder aus dem eu
haushalt bekommen deswegen haben viele
gefordert dass an den neuen eu-haushalt
eine rechtsstaats mechanismus geknüpft
werden muss wer so was macht der muss
damit rechnen dass gelder gekürzt werden
ja hat man gesagt ist das denn wirklich
in ordnung hat dagegen geklagt bis vor
den europäischen gerichtshof der hat
heute gesagt ja es geht das bedeutet
groß oder von der leyen muss jetzt
handeln kein geld mehr für eu-recht
staatssender
sehe ich komplett anders wenn anfangen
wenn wir anfangen staaten untereinander
wie ein bußgeldbescheid bei einem beim
falschparken zu bestrafen zu wollen dann
sind wir eigentlich da wo wir früher mit
krieg waren in europa wir haben es als
deutsche japaner versucht andere zu
disziplinieren jetzt geht es mit
bußgeldern sollen alle auf einen pfad
getrimmt werden so einfach ist es nicht
wenn wir europa erhalten wollen müssen
wir uns im klaren sein dass wir
unterschiedliche mentalitäten
unterschiedliche herangehensweise
irgendwie akzeptieren sonst können wir
gerne auch noch ein graben nach
osteuropa auf reisen dann haben wir die
nächsten länder die von der fahne gehen
dann ist europa
nicht an dem körperteil was ich jetzt
nicht nennen will so funktioniert es
einfach nicht nationen abzustrafen auch
aus brüssel auch im besten willen und
wissen und gewissen funktioniert nicht
und mit abgesehen davon muss man sich
auch mal ganz
selbstkritisch mal in aller stille
fragen wenn wir über polnische gerichte
her ziehen weil sie angeblich politisch
dominiert werden der wahlausschuss ist
selbstverständlich bei uns völlig
unpolitisch und dass da zwei hochrangige
cdu politiker mit drin sitzen ja das ist
aber die schalten das komplett ab die
essen zwar vorher mit der kanzlerin und
urteilen dann hinterher darüber ob die
kritik an der kanzlerin gerechtfertigt
war und an der korona politik aber das
ist völlig unparteiisch
selbstverständlich ironisieren jetzt
sieht man muss sich einfach vorstellen
wie diese zustände aus der sicht von
warschau aussehen und man kann wirklich
viktor orban eines mögliche vorwerfen
korruption ist zum beispiel großes
problem im lande aber das ja kein
europäer wäre das kann man nämlich
unterstellen und die grenzsicherung die
wir in belarus gefördert haben und die
wir in griechenland auf den an der
grenze zur türkei auch noch mit
eu-geldern gefördert haben die haben wir
bei viktor orban schwer kritisiert
obwohl er auch für uns die
migrationsströme abgebrochen hatte ich
frage mich jemand überhaupt auf die idee
kommen kann zu glauben dass das in
irgendeiner weise deutsche werte wären
die wir den polen oder den ungarn
aufzwingen wollten das sind unsere
gemeinsamen europäischen werte wir haben
den vertrag unterschrieben bestehende
regeln drin und da ist freiwillig gesagt
worden wir wollen damit machen übrigens
aus gutem grund und das ist auch eine
schöne sache weil europa endet nicht an
der oder sondern geht weiter erholen die
polnische nation ist eine stolze
europäischen nationen
vorbereiten was ihre schulen eigentlich
dabei mag schwierig
aber selbst nicht einfach lichter aus
dem amt ziehen weil sie damit nicht mehr
einverstanden sind was die machen
einfach so nicht also ich bin ja auch
sehr dafür dass wir der eu darauf achten
dass in allen staaten
rechtsstaatlichkeit und liberalität
gewahrt wird ich habe auch wenig
politische sympathien für orban und auch
nicht für die polnische regierung die
frage ist ja nur wenn man das fass
aufmacht wo es endet also ich erinnere
daran dass amnesty international vor
kurzem italien kritisiert hat wegen
einer völlig unverhältnismäßigen
diskriminierung einer minderheit nämlich
der restriktiven zweig maßnahmen am
arbeitsplatz gegen ungeimpfte also ich
meine amnesty international ist nun
schon eine größe wo ich sage wenn die
ein land kritisiert dann muss da schon
was im argen sein und wir haben ja
vorhin will jetzt das fass nicht noch
mal aufmachen aber auch über relativ
willkürliche grundrechte einschränkung
bei uns gesprochen oder auch zum
beispiel eine debatte die in deutschland
geführt wird immer stärker jetzt
irgendwie so eine art neuen
radikalenerlass also überprüfung beim
verfassungsschutz für bewerber im
öffentlichen dienst wo die frage auch
ist ist das denn dann wirklich also was
eure mittel geachtet weil ich
frage doch nicht dass wir jetzt in
deutschland aktuell auf dem level von
polen sind aber ich finde schon also
wenn muss man bei allen die gleichen
maßstäbe anlegen und eigentlich finde
ich sollte die eu eher so eine art
zusammenschluss souveräner staaten sein
wo man schon auch davon ausgeht dass die
unterschiedlich ihre inneren
angelegenheiten
richten weil sonst muss man tatsächlich
bei allen ländern dann mit gleichem
maßstab messen und ich weiß nicht ob die
ja wirklich diejenige ist die da ist ja
auch sagen als letzte instanz in frage
kommt das zu entscheiden man muss bei
allen staaten mit dem gleichen maßstäben
messen man muss sich auch mit der frage
beschäftigen ob in deutschland alles so
in ordnung ist ob die wahl von richtern
in deutschland wirklich der weisheit
letzter schluss ist weiß ich gar nicht
diskutieren wir das ändern wir das
machen was mehr demokratisch aber wir
müssen doch in eine bestimmte richtung
uns entwickeln und wir haben uns oft
bestimmte standards in der europäischen
union verständigt und wenn gesagt wird
also die richterliche unabhängigkeit die
passt der regierenden partei nicht
deswegen kicken wir die richter aus dem
amt dann ist das eine ganz gefährliche
der pandora sowie noch bei uns ja nicht
und ich will nur sagen weil ich auch
wert schätze das natürlich ein viktor
orban auch eine mehrheit in der
bayerischen bevölkerung für sich
gewonnen hat und auch die polnische
regierung ja wahlen gewonnen hat das
heißt wir können nicht einfach sagen wir
machen jetzt mal scharfe maßnahmen gegen
euch und dann werdet ihr hoffentlich
abgewählt sondern wir müssen schon auf
die polnische und die ungarische
bevölkerung vertrauen dass die eine
entscheidung treffen die sie selber
richtig finden denn das ist auch
demokratie aber eines will ich dazu
sagen
demokratie zeigt dafür muss dafür
mussten aus der minderheit auch noch
überhaupt eine mehrheit werden können
das ist der kern von demokratie dass man
überhaupt eine wahl gewinnen kann und
wenn die verfassung beliebig angepasst
wird wenn medienhäuser beliebig
dichtgemacht werden dann kann irgendwann
aus der minderheit keine mehrheit mehr
werden und deswegen muss man da
eingreifen und kann sich das nicht
bieten lassen und das sind gemeinsame
europäische werte was
so hat die europäische union nie
funktioniert wenn wir anfangen plötzlich
arbeits regeln zu machen für menschen
die in anderen pass haben denn wir
plötzlich güter nicht mehr exportieren
dürfen andere länder dann werden wir von
der eu auch bestreite ich bin leider ist
einfach miteinander zusammenhängt und
deswegen kein deutsches steuergeld mehr
was nach brüssel überwiesen wird um dann
ein rechtsstaat sünder bezahlt wird das
kann man doch nicht einfach gut
mir gefällt diese passion mir gefällt
dieser leidens erkannte er diese
leidenschaft ich bin nah bei ihnen
manchmal machen wir aber sorgen über die
ausgestaltung unter wirklich fast angst
vor einem system der gegenseitigen
schuldzuweisungen denn natürlich wenn
das so kommt stellt sich hin und sagt
liebe ungarn haben jetzt weniger geld
von der eu und das hat diese leute in
brüssel beschlossen und jetzt sage ich
euch mal was in deren ländern los ist
und dann macht er die top ten liste
aller da kommen wir auch vor mit
grundrechts einschränkungen keine ahnung
was oder richter bestand
klassischen europäischen ländern und
dann geht s wechselweise dann kommt der
rück- und dann haut sich quasi entlang
dieser eigentlich richtigen gedanken die
eu jede woche ein neues ding um die
ohren und jetzt kann man sagen dass es
dann der streit der zu einer
konstruktiven lösung wird ich habe so
ein bisschen zeige das dass er zu noch
mehr abkehr und noch mehr separatismus
sozusagen in der in der union führt
gedanklich oder vom vom impetus her bin
ich bei ihnen dass man natürlich
jemanden der rechtsstaatliche prinzipien
verletzt nicht auch nur das geld indes
meist gut aber der deal ist wir zahlen
alle in die kasse in brüssel ein und
dafür wird dann nach einem festen
schlüssel zb agrarförderung verteilt
jetzt kommt man aber an sagt jan
agrarförderung gut und schön aber
mir passt hier die schließung dieser
zeitung nicht die nur verkauft wurde an
einen anderen kann man sagen je schräger
diehl und so weiter alles gut und schön
bleiben wir doch im gespräch machen wir
doch erst mal geltend dass wir zusammen
ein großes europa sein wollen wir sagen
sonntags immer europa muss
zusammenbleiben um mehr gewicht zu
entfalten prima aber dann müssen wir
irgendwie im gespräch bleiben und können
sollten nicht versuchen uns gegenseitig
zu bestrafen und in osteuropa wird
dieses gebaren in brüssel als eine
ablassen als als eine bevormundung der
lässt die kanzlerin mehrere millionen
menschen in die europäische union
einreisen ihre koalition übrigens jetzt
jetzt massive migrations anreize die
dann aber alle europäischen länder
betreffen weil es entweder durch
reiseländer werden oder man sich im
schengen raum frei bewegen kann da
später fragt niemand in hungern vorher
nach ob denn der spurwechsel in
deutschland ob der genehm ist dass man
künftig dann vielleicht auch migranten
aus marokko bis nach budapest ziehen wir
können das ganze ja mal in einer
ungarischen universität in budapest zum
beispiel diskutieren das problem ist
dass viktor orban objektiv universitäten
also orte der debatten und der
diskussion aus dem land wirft also wenn
ich mal ne aufregung über cancel culture
hören will dann mal von viktor orban wo
leute aus dem land geschmissen werden
ich habe eine freie lehre wird ich habe
mich im neuen warenkorb ihres kolleg
frei austauschen können ja das glaube
ich sofort ist also auch ein ist ja auch
ein wunderschönes land und wunderbar
nette menschen mit denen man sich gut
unterhalten kann trotzdem kann man keine
universität aus dem land schmeißen das
ist doch